back in 2011 little British cousin
Sophia Grace and Rosie had taken the
world by storm with their cover of Nicki
Minaj's super vase
when Ellen invited them on her talk show
they became instant celebrities but
where are these girls now stay tuned to
find out everything you need to know
about Sophia Grace and Rosie all grown
up now let's find out what Sophia Grace
and Rosie are up to these days who are
Sophia Grace and Rosie if you were
watching anything on the internet back
in 2011
chances are you recognize Sophia Grace
and Rosie these two little girls were
cousins from Great Britain and they love
to sing Sophia Grace was just 8 years
old and Rosie was only five when their
first video went viral these two cousins
turned besties were obsessed with all
things pink in all things Nicki Minaj
they wore pink tutus with princess
tiaras and Sophia Grace could drop a
beat like no other Sophia Grace with the
star of the show but Rosie was just as
important she was there to dance and
provide support for her older more
outgoing cousin a hype girl if you will
love it or hate it
Nicki Minaj's song Super Bass was all
over the radio and Sophia Grace's cover
was on point Sophia Grace and Rosie
captured the heart of none other than
Ellen DeGeneres she flew Sophia Grace
and Rosie out and conducted what might
be the cutest interview of all time the
two little girls were so excited to be
on Ellen even Ellen could hardly stand
how cute they were we learned a lot
about their personalities in that
interview we learned that they were
obsessed with the color pink we learned
that Rosie is a lot higher than her
cousin and more of a hype girl and we
learned that Sophia Grace might be the
total opposite of shy after their
interview Ellen handed each of them a
microphone they did a live version of
Super Bass and the world was hooked
Ellen couldn't get enough of these
little pink rap stars she invited them
back a few months later they were still
wearing their pink tutus in tiaras and
they were still as cute as ever
this time Ellen had a huge surprise for
them they got to meet their idol Nicki
Minaj we're pretty sure no one has ever
been more excited about anything than
Sophia Grace was to meet Nicky Nicky
told the girls to stay in school and
that she was sending them on a shopping
spree then their dreams came true
they sang Super Bass with Nicky herself
Ellen featured Sophia Grace and Rosie
several more times she sent them to the
Grammys to do red carpet interviews
they got to meet mary j blige taio cruz
kitty purry and more these superstars
might have been even more excited to
meet Sophia Grace and Rosie then Ellen
sent the girls to Disneyland to meet the
princesses one time they even got slimed
on the show it was always exciting to
see Sophia Grace and Rosie on The Ellen
Show all grown up in 2018 Ellen
DeGeneres turned sixty years old as part
of her birthday special Sophia Grace and
Rosie filmed a birthday message for
their biggest fan Ellen wasn't the only
one shocked by how much they had grown
up in that birthday message rosie was
less shy and more confident and Sophia
Grace was just as outspoken as before as
Alan said Rosie would barely even talk
when she was little they shared their
favorite memories of Ellen and you could
tell just how special that was to the
host people started to wonder what these
two cousins were up to these days Rosie
McClelland you might be disappointed to
find out that Sophia Grace and Rosie
aren't a duo anymore there's still
cousins of course but their theme has
taken them on different paths and it's
been great for them so far so what is
Rosie up to these days as of January
2019
Rosie is 12 years old and she's a pretty
normal kid despite all her early fame
she has her own YouTube channel with
almost 600,000 subscribers Rosie goes to
a skate school and loves music she is a
self-described actress singer dancer and
model her YouTube channel is amazing she
posts music videos as a solo artist and
she's really talented she also post
various blogs and videos that show what
her life is like she's a normal teen she
even got braces as part of her 12 days
of Christmas videos we feel your pain
Rosie Rosie also has a pretty active
Instagram account with an impressive
half a million followers the account is
managed by her mom which makes sense
because Rosie is still so young
Rosie's middle name is Grace just like
her older cousin but unlike Sophia Rosie
just prefers to go by her first name she
has released her song and music video
handstands in 2018 this was a
collaboration with producer Jordan
Richmond and songwriters Heather Miley
and Griffith Frank they're the same team
that made Jo Jo see waz song boomerang
so popular it's pretty awesome that
they're working with Rosie now handstand
is a fun and up
seong it's set on a beach and is all
about looking at life through a positive
lens it's just so rosy and now rosie has
her own hype girls we love the
choreography in the video it's such a
catchy tune
Sophia Grace Brownlee Sophia Grace has
done a lot of growing up in the last
seven years and she wants you to know it
then now 15 year old is barely
recognizable she's no longer the pink
loving tutu wearing tiny diva that stole
our hearts and she's celebrating the
change one thing has stayed the same
though and that's Sophia Grace's love of
rap while her cousin Rosie has gone for
a more pop star image Sophia Grace is
building a career as a female rapper we
don't doubt that nicki minaj's influence
has something to do with this Sophia
Grace has been rapping for years now
just like her cousin Rosie Sophia Grace
has an active presence on YouTube and
she posts a little bit of everything she
does blogs about her life and advice
videos she interviews celebrities and
does makeup tutorials and she also posts
original music videos her music videos
have changed just as much as she has her
first videos like Hollywood and best
friends had a very pop star feel to them
she still looked young and her music
felt young but she has one amazing voice
in 2017 her video why you mad
looked a lot more grown-up she followed
that up with number one in August 2000
18 her deep jazzy voice was really
unique but the first week of 2019 marked
a huge change for Sophia Grace her first
rap song dropped can't sleep starts with
Sophia Grace talking about changing
she's tired of people expecting her to
be who she has always been but
everything changes including her she
raps about people's expectations and
becoming her own person the video is
Edgar than anything she's done before
and people were shook no one can believe
this is the same kid that talked about
how great the color pink is on The Ellen
Show Sophia Grace is also crazy active
on Instagram her account is pretty much
what you would expect from a teen girl
she posts lots of mirror selfies and
photos of her makeup and her makeup is
always on point she's stylish and
travels a lot we love seeing all the
places she goes to she's posted about a
boy and later about possible heartbreak
Sophia Grace is more or less a normal
teen girl who happened
to be fairly famous and she has over 1.3
million followers on her instead camp
which is pretty impressive Sophia Grace
is a lot more than just a budding Ellen
Show star she actually cares about a lot
of issues one Instagram post highlights
International Women's Day
she even interviewed Benedict
Cumberbatch on her YouTube channel
that's right none other than Doctor
Strange himself made an appearance on
her video he talked about bullying
gender equality and plenty of other hot
issues she's still a kid at heart though
she's made slime on her Channel
she did the bean boozled challenge with
Jojo sua
she was dared to dance awkwardly in
front of strangers at VidCon it seems
that she's a lot higher than she used to
be as a kid solo artists when they were
kids Sophia Grace and Rosie were joined
at the hip Sophia Grace was definitely
the leader of the pack as she was older
and more outgoing and they had a lot in
common both of these cousins were from
the same part of Essex who can forget
the adorable interview with Russell
Brand where they all talked about their
hometowns and in 2013 they went on ellen
to share the same big news both of their
mothers were pregnant they became big
sisters at about the same time they were
so excited and have been waiting their
whole lives according to Rosie Sophia
Grace had a little sister named Belle we
wonder if she dressed her in pink
leotards and to tooth like she wanted to
Rosie had a little brother named Romeo
we bet she got him a sparkly blue belt
like she told Ellen she would it seems
weird that Sophia Grace and Rosie aren't
a duo anymore we always imagined that
they would be together forever but as
they grew up they started going their
own way age difference starts to matter
a lot more when you get older you have
different interests now and their
musical styles are not very similar they
don't show up in each other's social
media very often anymore either but
they're both very busy girls they make
music and keep all their fans happy with
lots of great videos rosie has really
grown up and has come out of her shell a
lot she still seems to be interested in
a lot of girly things Sophia Grace is
more interested in normal teen stuff we
can't get enough of these two stars as
cute of a duo as they were going solo
seems to have been really great for
their careers they have different fan
bases and are able to make a whole new
generation of fans happy for those of us
who have been so
Grace and Rosie fans from the very
beginning it's pretty cool to see them
growing up they have become awesome
talented young ladies and we just love
their music and YouTube channels
Rosie always seems so happy she's honest
about life as a tween girl for example
she said she got the style of braces
that she did so she would fit in with
her friends Sophia Grace is definitely
living her best life she's traveling all
over and meeting lots of cool people
we're so happy to see these two girls
having such an amazing life and internet
career we don't know what to expect from
Sophia Grace and Rosie next it's been
several months since Rosie released her
song handstand it's doing great on
YouTube and we can't wait to see what
else she does hopefully she releases
some new songs soon in the meantime
we'll keep enjoying all her videos we
loved the tour of her house she did a
few months ago and her 12 days of
Christmas videos were so fun she's great
at creating authentic fun content we
love Rosie it's pretty cool how outgoing
she is now Sophia Grace just released
can't sleep the first week of 2019 it's
already got a ton of views on YouTube
it's also available on iTunes
she'll be writing the success of this
song for a while but now that she has
established herself as a rapper and not
a pop singer we're excited to hear more
rap she's talented at both singing and
rapping maybe she'll continue to merge
the two just like her old hero Nicki
Minaj what do you think of the new songs
by Sophia Grace and Rosie let us know in
the comments section below and that's
all you need to know about Sophia Grace
Brownlee and Rosie McClelland all grown
up be sure to LIKE this video and hit
that subscribe button for more awesome
content see you next time
[Music]